one of the most anticipated movies in
the summer comes to us from the director
of Jumanji and Jurassic Park 3 Captain
America you know I said that I thought
about it I'm surprised it took so long
for this movie to come to fruition
because they had a really cheesy
Maggie's movie that like everyone hates
but it's just so terrible and now all of
a sudden we have a really big budget
treatment of the comic book that a lot
of people love for Marvel it stars Chris
Evans as a hero we have Hugo Weaving as
the main villain Red Skull Tommy Lee
Jones and Hayley Atwell
as well as Stanley Tucci who I really
like this is a period piece phone back
when the war was going on and I think
that's really cool because I love how it
has that kind of raised the Lost Ark
feel to it I think Joe Johnston captured
it really well because he actually
worked on Raiders of the Lost Ark the
movies about this little guy with a big
heart is named Steve Rogers he's played
by Chris Evans he wants them in the army
but he's a little shrimpy guy and you
know no one really believes in him
except a few people and he really just
wants to he really wants to make it he
wants to fight for his country and
everything and he ends up getting sign
up for this program this this test he's
kind of a guinea pig for this new idea
where he gets pumped filled with this
stuff and he becomes a super soldier
through various ways he becomes known as
Captain America and he has to fight
against evil and everything in Red Skull
played by Hugo Weaving
I really had a lot of fun with Captain
America I really did I thought it was a
great superhero film and I liked it a
lot more than Green Lantern and more
than Thor even I'm not really sure about
x-men one of the things is really nice
about this movie is the look of the film
that the production value of this movie
is insane and I knew it was going to be
like that going in because all Joe
Johnston's movies look great the
production is always just
state-of-the-art one of the things that
gave me hope for this movie was Joe
Johnston directed a movie in 1991 called
The Rocketeer which is also a period
piece comic-book adaptation and
basically a superhero movie and I really
liked that movie was a lot of fun and
this film has a really similar feel
Chris Evans did a really nice job as
Captain America he he bulked up
in regards to Captain America's origin
in the comics I am a total noob I really
only know the basics and nothing else so
I'm judging this film purely from a
filmmaking standpoint and I really
enjoyed it I had a lot of fun with it I
think that Hugo Weaving I love Hugo
Weaving so much I mean the matrix Lord
of the Rings Megatron V for Vendetta
now this that guy he is just awesome
that guy who's is awesome Hugo Weaving
is so good in this movie and he is by
far my favorite superhero villain of the
year the look of Chris Evans when he's a
little shrimpy kid it's perfect
it is 100% convincing red skull looks so
awesome
every little facial twitch that Hugo
Weaving was giving it looked it just
worked perfectly to the performance I
love the special effects this movie they
were excellent one of the things I was
really worried about was how are they
going to get past the cheesiness of a
real soldier deciding to dress up like
that he did a really good job of that
I'm not gonna go into details but they
did a really good job of actually making
me convincing that the guy would end up
calling himself Captain America and wear
the outfit and the shield and everything
and it worked I like the outfit timely
Jones is in the fugitive mode and when I
say that it's the mode read as walks
around straight face giving orders and
if southern accent you're gonna go out
dinner you do that thing right there
yeah that's why I thought yeah okay yeah
I'm title he goes mmm yeah all right
Hugo Weaving really stole the show for
me here this movie was just I loved him
so much every time they came on scans
like yes also al Silvestri score is
excellent his theme is very good and I
think this is my favorite score kiss
since predator all know basically Marvel
has completely destroyed DC this year
and it wasn't too patriotic and that's
one of the things I really liked was
even though it was all like you're
America it's great and everything it
didn't like shove it in your face some
of the flaws I had in the film where it
is extremely hokey and corny at times I
think it's kind of relishing the fact
that they know so it's a little cheesy
with the Captain America and all that it
is a little slower parts I felt like
there made me needed to be some more
action in some scenes also the first
half of the film feels like its own
movie which was very good and
second half of the film feels like a
completely different movie which maybe
wasn't as good as the first half but
still a lot of fun for some reason they
did not show The Avengers teaser at my
screening I found out they weren't
showing it for any of the critics
screenings so I was a little ticked off
about that but I watched the leaked
version and I couldn't see a thing and
so I can't really say much about that
the ladies will enjoy Chris Evans the
guys will enjoy everything else and
maybe Chris Evans - who knows I enjoyed
Captain America a lot I'm going to give
it three and a half out of four stars so
stay tuned because tomorrow and see
Crazy Stupid Love is screening and I'll
let you know what I think of that too so
if you liked this review subscribe to my
channel get stuntman ID
[Music]